well the latitude is complete there now
there now let me look back today if
you've actually read the Bill of Rights
and the 14th amendment some of the some
of the provisions are precise they're
the ones that are the real embarrassment
right so you have the seventh amendment
says that you're entitled to a jury
trial in a civil case you may exclude
this injunction case but in any civil
case where the amount in controversy is
more than $20 well that's ridiculous
that's $20 in 18th century term it's
it's it's an embarrassment right it it
results it results in entitling people
to jury trials and in tiny tiny federal
cases so it's ridiculous but but it's
hard to get around then there are
provisions which also are embarrassingly
precise but like the second immense
Breen Court has just taken this second
amendment you're right to have a gun
and they're they so if you read the
Second Amendment literally right to bear
arms you know
seems pretty broad but the courts
traditionally have kind of ignored that
now I don't know what the Supreme Court
will do
another example is but so so precision
you know when you have a constitutional
provision that's you know more than 200
years old if it's very precisely stated
it's likely to fall out you know likely
to to bear no relation to contemporary
need that's a problem and then you don't
know what what you know I give you an
exact letter example there is the
example it's like you know not in the
Bill of Rights but anywhere in the body
of the Constitution it there's it says
that Congress can create and fund and so
on an army and a navy but there's no
reference to an airforce
right so there's no problem in simply
having the Army and the Navy having an
aviation arm that's no problem when the
weapons change but to create an Air
Force as a separate a branch of the
Armed Services is not actually
authorized by time and in the
Constitution but that was just ignored
they created the Air Force no one minds
so some provisions are simply ignored
the other provisions the ones that are
vague are simply given a modern a modern
meeting and even Justice Scalia accepts
that so the the Eighth Amendment forbids
cruel and unusual punishments and if you
were a real originalist you would say
well let's look in the 18th century what
was considered cruel and unusual and one
of the things that wasn't considered
cruel it certainly was not unusual was
public flogging but Justice Scalia said
he believes that no public flogging
would today violate the Eighth Amendment
and
the the sixth amendment creates a right
to counsel in criminal cases well it's
perfectly clear historically it's also
pretty clear from the text that all I
meant by that was you could hire a
lawyer in a criminal case nothing about
the state the government paying for a
lawyer couldn't afford one nothing like
that or the Fifth Amendment
self-incrimination clause is quite clear
from the text and from the from the
history that they couldn't force a
person in a trial or some other you know
proceeding which he's testifying to
incriminate himself but that didn't mean
they couldn't force him to confess
outside the trial and then use that in
some fashion in the trial so almost the
entire body of constitutional law was
created by the Supreme Court justices by
free interpretation or no interpretation
of the Constitution just using the
Constitution as a jumping-off point and
clearly when you get to the sex cases
you know what the boys no case nothing I
mean so you can take the word like
liberty and say oh yeah Liberty sex song
but that doesn't have anything to do
with 18th century thinking or with
anything in the text except words
they're so vague they can be applied to
any anything that bothers you you can
say infringes Liberty so so that the
text doesn't impose a limit precedent
doesn't impose them there might be I
mean there's obviously a circular
Supreme Court justices make up some
principle like they say for example that
you need a warrant to search a person so
I'll actually read the Fourth Amendment
there's nothing about requiring a
warrant fourth amendment limits warrants
because the framers of the Constitution
were concerned
if a search was conducted pursuant to a
warrant it gave the searching officer
and immunity from his suit so didn't
like warrants but the Supreme Court
turned that on its head said you need a
warrant
so the fact that they've but they said
that you can say well that's a precedent
now if judges follow that they're just
applying the law they're not making
anything up but they are applying
something which was itself made up by
judges and the Supreme Court is not
bound by its precedents goes overruling
them or it couldn't say it can you know
distinguish them to death it can distort
what they say so they have a complete
free game except for public opinion
which might precipitate a constitutional
amendment so there's some things they
can't do but but but that's the only
real limit now at our level we have
freedom in areas where the Supreme Court
hasn't spoken but we do obviously have
to follow the Supreme Court otherwise
they'll reverse us and humiliate us we
have to follow the Supreme Court so
we're more cuz we're more like real
judges because we have more constraints
on us then
you